the Nomi Prins discusses our current
economic situation in the US and her
book black Tuesday a historical novel
about the 1929 economic crash this is
about an hour 20 minutes
good evening I want to welcome everybody
to the Strand
I hope you enjoy our new event space
which is located in our rare book floor
as a way of introduction I'm Nancy Wyden
I'm the owner of the Strand the Strand
was founded by my grandfather in 1927
it's been around for three generations
of my family so a contrary to the
so-called experts who say the Kindles
and the iPads and the next cool devices
are going to wipe out bookstores we
believe that people do not want to just
be sitting home at home tethered to
their gadgets even though I see Matt
brought his devices it's dark but we're
just planning to serve the book
community for a long long time tonight I
am thrilled to wait welcome back Naomi
prims for the launch of her first
historical novel black Tuesday this is
the second time that she's been at the
Strand and she says that she only signs
at independent bookstores love her for
that so with the mounting frustration
with Wall Street and the recession this
novel and topic is extremely tiny timely
so this and thank you special thank you
to demos the nonpartisan multi-issue
think-tank for co-sponsoring this event
and they're located here in New York
City so we have we have a lively group
of panelists here tonight none of which
are afraid of controversy including Matt
- b2b Lee and rich Benjamin that's who
talk about the current financial climate
back Tuesday is a black Tuesday as a
character-driven book that vividly
portrays New York on the cusp of the
great stock market crash of 1929 it
captures the romance and desperation of
one of the most
fascinating historical times Nomi Prins
left a lucrative career at Goldman Sachs
and Bear Stearns after a decade to pen
three nonfiction whistleblower books
it takes a pillage other people's money
and arson and jacked exposing fraud and
deception from Wall Street to Washington
her first novel the trail is a thriller
set in the corrupt banking world and it
was written under sumin you don't have
to tell us why and but she's a senior
fellow at demos and a frequent
commentator for all kinds of media PBS
Fox my Fox MSNBC CNBC CNN BBC and other
global media outlets matt is a
contributing editor for Rolling Stone he
writes about politics and finance in one
article he famously described Goldman
Sachs as a great vampire squid wrapped
about the face of humanity relentlessly
jamming its blood funnel into anything
that smells like money he's authored
five books many of which we have here
including the New York Times bestseller
great derangement and Griff topia
and he's recently became a contributor
for current TV's countdown with Keith
Oberman a rich Benjamin down at the end
is the author searching for whitopia an
improbable journey to the heart of white
America which was the winner of 2009
Editors Choice Award from book lists and
the American Library Association rich
regularly appears all over the media
including on NPR MSNBC c-span New York
Times USA Today and cnn.com he's a
contributing producer of sort short
documentaries for time.com in
partnership with CNN and he's a senior
fellow at demos so for a little bit of
tonight's format we're gonna have a
conversation then we want to open up the
mic to your questions it's a
really big crowd here so if you don't
mind just standing standing up and I'll
hand you them and just waiting a second
for me to hand you the mic so everybody
can hear you and then the authors are
gonna stick around and sign copies of
their books also a special thanks to
c-span for filming tonight
and for the work they do to inspire and
educate us so please join me in
welcoming some of the America's great
contemporary whistleblowers and
advocates of financial reform
Naomi prims and her panelists to the
Strand thank you all
hi my name is rich Benjamin I'm a senior
fellow at demos and first of all I'd
like to welcome you guys who make this
event possible and I want to thank
strands such a beloved beloved
institution for we booklovers here in
New York and I want to thank demos which
as Nancy mentioned is a multi-issue
think-tank which works for three
overarching goals the first of which is
a more equitable prosperous economy the
second of which is the democracy where
more of us can participate and the third
of which is a public sector that works
for the common good now I want to offer
a different angle in introducing our
other panelists I got this email in July
from Noemi and it said hey rich I've
written a novel called black Tuesday
right here and I'm thinking word Noemi
wrote a book about african-american
Tuesday to clarify black Tuesday of
course referring to dark Tuesday in the
stock market crash of 1929 and
immediately I could see the timeliness
of this topic although no me could write
a book called african-american Tuesday
now for those of you who don't know know
me in such a dogged incisive elegant
voice for progressive values and I'm so
honored to introduce her what you may
not know in which was
alluded to before is no me was part of
the 1% before she joined the 99% no me
was a Wall Streeter and not only was she
a Wall Streeter she was a managing
director at Goldman Sachs which is such
an achievement in itself in terms of her
brilliance but now she's based in LA and
she's writing full-time and I want to
briefly show you her novels because that
really gives a wonderful trajectory of
her thinking and her career the first
other people's money the corporate
mugging of America secondly checked how
conservatives are picking your pocket
whether you voted for them or not third
whistleblowing book it takes a pillage
behind the bailouts bonuses and backroom
deals from Wall Street to Washington by
the way Nomi is also the queen of titles
in case you hadn't noticed so you can
learn more about Nomi at WME Prince calm
and I just introduced her with a great
deal of pride and a great deal of
affection and we miss her here on the
right coast so know me Prince now Matt
Taibbi you might figure you know Matt's
a bit of an underachiever and a boring
writers seriously matt is a regular
contributor for Rolling Stone and he has
made such a name to really exposing the
underbelly in the dark side of our
financial institutions in this country
you read the beautiful quote that Matt
had to say about noemi's former employer
goldman sachs and i'll briefly read from
mass blog today you can find Matt at his
rolling stone blog when he's not on
countdown
Matt wrote today quote but nobody is
comfortable with is a movement in which
virtually the entire spectrum of
middle-class and poor Americans is on
the same page railing against incestuous
political and financial corruption on
Wall Street and in Washington the
reality is that Occupy Wall Street and
the millions of middle Americans who
make up the Tea Party are natural allies
it should be on the same page about most
of the key issues and that's a story our
media won't want you to know for you to
handle
I have a gripe to pick with Matt as
Nancy mentioned I published a book
called searching for white topia in 2009
an improbable journey to the heart of
white America in 2010 Matt released
Griff topia bubble machine vampire
squids and the long con that is
breathtaking that is breaking America so
please visit Matt and welcome Matt and
Matt we're delighted to have you
let's just jump right in what we'll do
is we'll have a conversation and then
we'll open it up to questions and Noemi
let's hear about black Tuesday well
thank you for the introduction Thank You
Nancy for that lovely introduction Thank
You strand thank demos thank the Lower
East Side Tenement Museum where I spent
a lot of time it took a lot of tours
doing some of the research for this book
Thank You grandfather for two years
before the time that this book took
place starting this bookstore because a
lot has happened and it's wonderful to
gather here tonight for that obviously a
lot going on in the world with respect
to and particularly in New York on Wall
Street and so forth that were just
talking about that Matt talks about with
respect to what is an uprising amongst
people who are just sick of the way
things are economically
and want it to actually be different not
to have talked about how it might be
different but to actually live
differently and I we are I'm sure going
to talk about that a lot tonight but
what I want to do first is take you back
82 years to a period in time that was
both very different and very similar to
today and that was part of my
inspiration for coming up with the story
for this book is that a lot of what what
I do what rich does what Matt does you
know we talk about numbers we do talk
about people who talk about stats but
it's really in a novel that you can also
look at the emotions behind that the
sort of the sheer humanity of struggling
and of what you bear and what you think
you don't want to deal with and what you
ultimately come to achieve and there's a
lot of that in this book to know one's a
natural hero
least of all the main character Lila
Khan she comes to what she ultimately
does in this book through a lot of
internal struggle and a lot of different
situations
I'm gonna read three brief passages from
the book to give you a sense of you know
what she went through what things were
like on both sides of the divide the 1%
the 99% but back then and it wasn't too
different and go from there so the first
passage Lila lives in this fifth floor
walk-up on Orchard Street in an
apartment that she shares with four
other people her her old aunt Rosa her
little sister Rachel and her two cousins
and it's tiny and cramped as as you can
imagine back in the 20s back in that day
back at that time and she's having a
conversation with her aunt about this
idealism that she's seeing the sort of
activism that's kind of happening
amongst the workers and the people she
knows on that side and how she really
feels about it which is which is not
sure Lila eyed her aunts hallowed
cheekbones and defiant limbs the silver
streaks in the wiry Raven hair that she
wore braided down her back she felt her
throat constrict listen to me go on said
Rosa with a labored flick of her wrists
of
things will be fine enough with this
source how are things with you and
Nelson financier Lila that's all just
fine I don't know I wish he could be
happier he's always going on about how
miserable things are fighting about
something ever since his brother was
shot I'm afraid he may join the gangs
again I guess I guess I'm tired of it
I'm tired of not being a fighter he
thinks I should be Rosa nodded and
swayed her body back and forth her eyes
closed as they transported her to the
internal movie of her past he's a good
man
with a loyal heart you should try to see
where he's coming from should should
should
Rosa's words made Lila feel inadequate
she could not help but think of the
stranger at the mourning spot
good morning spots a diner down on Wall
Street did he have any warmth any
goodness she knew nothing about him and
yet he had somehow burrowed into her
heart
I know replied Lila but but that won't
make him easier to deal with you
remember what I told you when you first
came here a young girl of 14 not knowing
a word of English she asked I do tanta
Lila braced herself her speech she'd
heard many times before it was her duty
to listen diligently but her heart
impelled her to flee she loved her aunt
with all her being but that love imposed
a burden that she wished she could shake
I told you that in order to succeed in
America you must find your purpose and
always help those less fortunate than
you I know which is exactly what Nelson
strives to do every day I know it's just
that you and he have such courage does
patience I wish I did instead I just
want to get out of here Lila stopped
herself but Rosa seemed to understand
exactly what she meant sometimes you
don't find your cause Leila said her
aunt with a little smile your cause
finds you there was a little fight
buried in all of us and that's kind of
one of the messages in the book is that
you know not all of us start out knowing
anything about the direction of our life
were or fights we might have or how we
might react in those particular
situations I mean certainly when I
started on Wall Street I was Lila's age
I was 19 and I had no idea what it was
about and it took me working there many
many years to finally finally figure it
out and ultimately to get out and share
it but but you don't know you don't know
the answers and
and you don't always do the right thing
and I think that's that's a part of all
of us and sometimes you come upon the
right thing in a really difficult way
one other scene I'm gonna read this one
and one more this is a scene where now
she's Lila is working on on this in this
diner on Wall Street and she goes home
every night to this dingy little
apartment on the Lower East Side not not
very far away at all but but millions of
miles away in terms of the conversations
that happen and the money divided and
everything else but she's just
discovered a secret about this Wall
Street banker who comes to frequent her
diner
Lila arrived home to a glorious May
evening vibrant swaths of magenta
tangerine and Rose striped the blue dusk
sky like the swirls around the candy
canes at Cohen's sweet shop on Rivington
Street the air carried a gentle breeze
throughout the Lower East Side Lila was
so gleefully distracted with thoughts of
Roderick and the Morgans that she
circled her neighborhood several times
before reaching her building Rachel is
planck's tuple with a few of her friends
the brow under her Raven bring glitz was
damp with a sweat of competition they're
building how the tallest stoop in the
neighborhood seven steps in also it was
a magnet for kids children were laughing
and scampering after every stray ball
that bounced down the sidewalk
the twins were unofficial neighborhood
champs Jonathan would wind his arm like
a Yankee pitcher on opening night he
could go 20 points without missing a
catch and finish a game with a hundred
points Joshua had stopped playing a few
years ago hey cuz Jonathan called to
Lila mid pitch his hair toss old mess
the sleeves of his work shirt rolled up
to his elbows your sisters gaining on me
she's out to take my title it's war
I bet on Rachel by the left is that all
my talent means to you ask Jonathan
grinning sorry Jonathan rage is no
slouch we all better watch out for her
and would you mind making room for me to
pass through the big game do we have to
stop now moaned Rachel I'm having my
best run of course you don't
Rikka answered arriving breathless at
their stoop she hung on to the iron
railing her ample breasts breathing
heaving I haven't seen your sister in
weeks we're gonna do a little catch-up
so keep beating Jonathan okay okay
agreed Rachel grabbing the ball not
needing the extra encouragement
rifka Lila hugged her friends so good to
see you but I'm late for dinner
Rosa
be waiting for me to help with the
finishing touches Rosa definitely does
not need your help in the cooking
department briefca chuckled now tell me
what's new please my life is one big
bore right now I need to come up with
better fish stories for Josh or move on
it's tragic
how's your crush Lila couldn't suppress
a wide grin that Unleashed tread in
polls see there's news exclaim Risa tell
me okay but let's go over to Feinberg
hardware away from his big ears over
there she gestured to Rachel the two
locked a few buildings down the block
they strode past Marcus's Shoe Store and
Herald cigar shop sniffing wafts of
sweet tobacco they passed another set of
kids playing hopscotch in a third
playing stickball everyone was out
tonight after they sat down on Feinberg
steps Lila blurted out the latest
development are you kidding me Reef cos
emerald eyes nearly bulged out of their
sockets
he's a Morgan flesh and blood of the
richest man in the world and he talks to
you and that was part of what was going
on at the time there was there was a a
cynicism amongst a very small group of
people about what went down on Wall
Street because it was it was very
secretive there were bankers down there
there was money made down there there
was a stock market everybody was talking
about but but it was still pretty
secretive and it still is today but but
it was even more so then and yet there
was this adoration of it like it must be
so amazing you know those guys making
this money what are they doing what what
what what crazy things are going on down
there and until the market really
crashed and things got really bad that
there wasn't this notion of a connection
between those things that went down
there and how it was impacting a stupe
ballgame on the steps on Orchard Street
and just as a background to that one of
the women that I had interviewed and I
talked to a lot of people about there
were some experiences during the Great
Depression it was kind of a little bit
Rachael who is the little sister of Lila
the main character and she used to tell
me that they didn't have a lot of money
so they would they would have a ball and
this ball would be basically everybody's
game and it was stupid you'd find the
stairs and you basically throw the ball
catch it and there'd be like these
tournaments going on on the streets you
know you'd find a stick you play
stickball
whereas uptown on Park Avenue and so
forth you had all of the the latest toys
the latest fashions the latest
everything and it was a tremendous
tremendous difference as again it is
today
even even more pronounced back then but
obviously there's there's a cost that
comes with that difference on our
economy on people on people back then
and the bankers that ultimately
perpetuate some of what happens don't
always know what they're doing and some
do and herein lies the problem her crush
is a Morgan partner in real life there
were 40 partners at Morgan Bank he was
the 41st in my book but has a lot of the
elements of the others so this last
scene I'm going to read will probably
take you into today a little bit but it
was the afternoon for real of 1929
October Tuesday 1929 the 29th and
Roderick the Morgan partner had to go
into the secret meeting at the New York
Stock Exchange right now if you imagine
the triangle down on Wall Street there's
the Stock Exchange there's the old
Morgan Bank which was the the first big
Morgan Bank and then there's Federal
Hall it's kind of a triangle obviously
was the same then and for real they in
the middle of the state when the market
was going crazy and crashing there was a
notice given to the morgan bank that
there was going to be a secret meeting
held at the new york stock exchange to
talk about what to do
bankers had several days before that on
Black Thursday pool lots of their money
together and thought they could save the
markets and they did for a little bit in
the media so that was all great and then
they all plummeted again and so now
there are several days later and they
know they know that everything they've
basically created and lied about is
going to come crumbling down so there's
a secret may of the New York Stock
Exchange to decide what to do and it was
told to people that were coming over
from from Morgan not to let anybody
basically see them come over because
that would incite a riot you know
imagine there's all these people down in
the exchange everybody's angry and and
the actual this was only reported much
later it wasn't reported at the time the
meeting that was held was actually held
in secret they went up the back stairs
of the exchange
to avoid being caught the exchange was
the last place Rodrick wanted to be
it was just like his uncle to stay away
from the fray always in the shadows he
grabbed his overcoat and hat and
followed Lamont from across the lower
lobby of Morgan
Roderick saw a cluster of men before the
bank's doors yelling at the Morgan
guards with fists clenching stock
certificates Lamont said not that way
out the back the two men exited the bank
for the same steel doors that normally
opened four truckloads of gold bars once
outside they had no choice but to barge
through the crowds to reach the back
door of the exchange across the narrow
street fortunately there were less
people on this side of the exchanges and
raging directly in front of it but the
task was still far from simple just when
they reached the back of the exchange
two guards told him to wait outside so
that people wouldn't spot to Morgan
partners entering they might just kill
you said an exchange guard
Ryder gestured his hat to cover his eyes
and waited by Lamont he was looking down
at his shoes when a man wearing a gray
overcoat and matching bowler hat marched
up to him and punched him in the stomach
Roderick doubled over me rot in hell
said the man before he spit in Rodricks
face and ran off on that happy note
there there was obviously a lot of
visceral anger back then we see that
anger today but when I started writing
this book it it was the story the notion
of this young girl who really didn't
know anything about any of this not
about bankers not about Wall Street not
about fighting not about labor activists
you know she just wanted to grow up in
this America have the dream that
everyone talked about when they
immigrated here and and that was all and
she comes upon what some discoveries
that she can't ignore even though she
tries really hard to and that's a lot of
the conflict in the book is that you
know sometimes you ignore ignore ignore
until until you can't and and what do we
do at that moment of our humanity or our
situation in our personal lives in an
aggregate situation for the country or
whatever to stand up and what's our
internal struggle in doing that so she
does go through a lot of that and I
think today there's there's a lot of the
now I mean there's a lot of anger
there's there's Matt's quote there is
all of the stuff that we know has been
imposed upon the economy on the
conditions of this country by virtue of
criminal activity by virtue of fraud by
virtue of inflating the value of things
that shouldn't be inflated and and what
we're seeing now is really no different
the details might be different but but
the mechanisms the people are all the
same really they're just you know like
like Nancy's here instead of a
grandfather you know it's like Jamie
Dimon is here instead of Jack Morgan but
in in a in a worse way and and I think
that's also the impetus for learning
from our past and hoping that you know
maybe we can bring the good parts of
what happened in that past forward
because not all of the bankers at this
time got what they should have gotten
not that none of them were actually
arrested none of them were actually
tried for securities fraud or anything
like that at the time but and which is
very familiar which I know Matt will
talk about but we did that we did have a
situation where there was an
understanding that the country had to be
protected and that in the midst of the
Great Depression that follow the stock
market crash in 1929 the the foundation
of the country that the core of of the
financial system had to be protected
visa vie the population and that was
part of the reason why they split up the
banks ultimately in 1933 it was the idea
that you can't be doing fraudulent
things and then crash the whole economy
however does that happens and either a
get away with it or B get to continue
doing it with our help
ie the government's help and so back
then they have that distinction they
have the glass-steagall Act passed which
divided banks and basically slapped back
not there all the speculative activities
but at least gave the population
protections that we don't have now which
is a sad lack of historical
understanding in today's world but all
of that aside going through it at the
time and if you can imagine going back
and seeing kind of simpler world
as a person just coming here and
figuring it out with their heart with
their head struggling between family
struggling between the wealthy and the
poor and everything else you know you
get a sense for how we are really not
that different from from how we were 82
years ago
in addition before he starts responding
know nothing when he wrote the piece
about the vampire squid which was my old
old firm I had so many calls about him
and we didn't we didn't actually know
each other at the time it was it was
sort of like who is this you know I mean
I I knew his work right I didn't know
him we hadn't had a personal
conversation I think I had so many calls
about that piece and about the sky that
I reached out and I'm just glad to say
we you know have become friends and I
deeply admire this man's work and I'm
sure you guys all do too it was great I
have a lot to say about know me but just
a couple of really quick things before I
start first of all rich I'm really sorry
for stealing your title I didn't you
know I saw it I think that sounds catchy
I'll take that second thing before we go
on I just want to say how cool it is for
me personally to be able to appear at
the Strand I've been buying books from
those bins outside since I was like this
tall and like literally half the books
in my bookshelves come from the store
and in one form or another either this
one or the one that used to be downtown
so my wife who needs to go there every
weekend and come out with you know
stacks this big so this is a big honor
for me and I'm very happy to be here I'm
glad you all came out tonight
oh this is this is a great for me to be
able to come out and talk about know me
and noemi's book just to explain a
little bit about where I'm coming from
with regard to to know me and watch what
I think she meant to this period to a
lot of journalists like me I just want
to tell my story about how I came to
know
I think my my story was kind of typical
for a lot of political journalists up
until 2008 most people who cover
politics in you know national American
politics really didn't know anything
about economics at all our whole modus
operandi for covering politics was
covering the economy excuse me was to
look at the stock market and inflation
and maybe unemployment figures and and
that was it if the stock market was up
we would say the economy was good and if
the inflation was low the economy was
good and that was really about it most
people didn't understand anything else I
can tell you that with a hundred percent
certainty that the people on the
campaign trail who cover politics for a
living know absolutely nothing about
economics and we won one of the the sort
of precipitating incidents for me is
there something we can do about that
feedback no okay does everyone remember
the whole drill baby drill speech that
McCain did in the summer of 2008 while I
was on I was covering McCain I was on a
campaign plane and I remember we were in
Kenner Louisiana he was sort of
unveiling a new version of that speech
and you know after and of course we
McCain was talking about was this the
surge in gas prices that summer everyone
remember gas prices went through the
roof and he was basically saying oh if
we just drilled in the Gulf of Mexico
than those you know somehow that would
magically make gas prices go down so he
gives this speech and all the reporters
are filing back into the our little you
know private prison which is the
campaign plane and and and one of the TV
reporters is like when McCain what a
jerk you know as if as if drilling in
the Gulf of Mexico has anything to do
with why gas prices are going up and I
kind of turned to him and I'm gonna
raise my hand and I said does anybody
here actually know why gas prices are
going up and it was like the cartoons
you know where the crickets come in you
know
literally nobody knew and I and I kind
of turned to one of these when another
reporter who is sitting next to me and
I'm like doesn't that make us all frauds
and he's like dude you're just figuring
that out now
so so there was that you know it's so so
then the crash happens like you know a
couple of months later and suddenly this
whole army of ignoramuses who don't know
anything about the economy are suddenly
given these assignments like go figure
out what just happened and until
everybody else about it like you're an
expert and so I was one of those people
who was like given this daunting
assignment of explaining all of these
labyrinthine you know mashing nations
that led to the financial crisis of 2008
and I was one of the people who didn't
even know how to balance a checkbook so
I'm starting from square one and I
remember I started making a whole bunch
of calls to people in the industry and I
remember like the first time somebody
explained I credit default swaps to me
and they were saying oh you know to
financial institutions are basically
making they sign a contract with each
other and if you know X person defaults
on his loan then this Bank gets the full
value of the the loan but if he doesn't
default on it then this person continues
paying that that party you know a
regular payment every month and I'm
sitting here listening to this and like
that sounds just like gambling you know
that is that economics and you know
these guys on Wall Street who are
calling they were saying no no you don't
understand it's it's very sophisticated
it's it's not it's not just gambling
it's really it's a it's a mechanism for
lessening risk and you know they had all
this verbiage that they were cloaking
all of us in but it sounded really fishy
to me and then you know then then it got
into collateralized debt obligations and
you know the more people explained this
to me I you know I was I was talking to
them and I was saying so let me get this
straight so you take a whole bunch of
subprime loans that are basically
worthless or junk rated they're
extremely risky and then you somehow
sprinkle a bunch of magic dust on them
and they turn into triple-a rated loans
that you can sell to pension funds and
you know Dutch trade unions and other
victims all around the globe and and
they're like yeah I know and then I'm
like well but that sounds just like the
guys on the street who
so Prada Bags and you know Gucci watches
they're not really you know how is that
any different from just crime and and
they're like now you don't understand
it's it's you know it's economics it's
it's a risk management tool it's you
know it's it's creates liquidity that's
the phrase they always use or it's it
creates liquidity so you know your
instinct is to say is to like run with a
headline that just says craziest [ __ ]
imaginable you know like like this can't
possibly be happening and but I think
like a lot of reporters you know I I was
hesitant because most of us had never
met any people from that world you know
none of us had any actual access to
people like Lloyd Blankfein or Jamie
Dimon we didn't get the talk to them I
mean even even presidential candidates
when most of us have gotten to sit down
and talk to these people but we don't
have access to the captains of finance
and at least political reporters don't
and and so we didn't really know how it
worked and and so a lot of us were
really hesitant to make judgments about
it and you an add to the fact that the
entire financial press was treating what
happened as just sort of a grotesque
accident and you know a thousand-year
flood this this is just you know
economics these things happen it wasn't
crime it wasn't fraud it you know it's
just a whole bunch of people who made
some bad judgments about the market and
these are seemingly smart people on
television and there's a whole army of
people on CNBC who are acting like this
isn't crazy and that it isn't crime and
so you you hesitate because you don't
have that personal experience and and so
what was really needed was for somebody
from that world to come forward and
explain to us yes this is this was nuts
it's exactly as crazy as crazy as it
seems like and moreover let me tell you
a little bit about what these people are
like so you can understand the
motivations in the background and that's
really what no me I think noemi's role
has been in this entire fiasco she's she
was one of the first sort of wit first
person witnesses to history to come
forward and to confirm the superficial
conclusions that all these outsiders
were drawing but we just didn't we
couldn't know for sure unless we had
buddy who was actually on the inside
explaining a lot of this to us and you
know I I had the it was shortly after I
think my Goldman piece came out I forget
who called who first but but we ended up
meeting in New York in in a Jewish deli
in the diamond district
yeah they closed at the dairy luncheon
there anyone know that place and we sat
and no me basically soon as she ran
through her the history of her
experiences that you know particularly
at Bear Stearns and Goldman and she told
me a lot about what you know her career
had been like and what her apprehensions
were and why she ended up leaving and
and you know for me it was as a reporter
was it was invaluable because you know
not just confirming intellectually what
all these instruments were and how they
worked and and why why they blew up but
it was also you know what how these what
the rooms look like where they where
these deals went down what the attitude
was of the people who were who are doing
these deals you know it from from on the
outside one has the one comes to the
conclusion that these people must have
been looking at you know numbers there
must have been internal objections
people in the risk management
departments coming forward saying don't
we can't do this it's gonna blow up the
company and there must have been people
who said you know forget about that
we'll worry about that later and and it
wasn't until I met Noemi that I that I
realized that you know that I had
somebody to tell me yes first hand yes
this did happen yes these people were
routinely ignored and that's why a lot
of these disasters happen so all of us
you know that there weren't a whole lot
of people from this world who came who
came forward to tell us what it was like
on the inside and so she's really an
invaluable resource in that regard and I
think you know what what she's able to
do with black Tuesday there there are a
lot of things that we can't imagine
except in the realm of fiction because
they couldn't possibly happen in reality
like for instance we're never gonna have
a trial a fraud trial of a Jamie Dimon
or a Lloyd Blankfein in this country
it's just work these people are not
going to be dragged into court and
forced to answer
for their crimes and make no mistake
about it this is another key point that
no me her experience brings out and she
bears out in the book you know there
were a lot of people who were trying to
say that what happened in the crash was
the work of a few bad apples here on the
side and underlings that the guys up at
the top couldn't possibly have been
aware that they were selling you know
miss March instruments knowingly and
unloading them on customers that's
complete crap these none of us could
have happened without the full and total
participation of the guy at the very
guys at the very top of these companies
and she makes that plain but the her her
novel comes to a crescendo at the end
and there's a there's a trial scene
where a character of the Jack Morgan
character who's you know sort of like
Titan of industry is actually dragged
into court for fraud and forced to you
know come face to face with the people
who bought these you know these dicey
investment trusts which are very similar
to the to the CEOs of our modern time
although they were a little bit more
primitive and that's exactly what we're
not going to see now as everyone heard
about this foreclosure deal that the
AG's are cooking up now the state
attorneys general that's going to be
sort of a unified settlement that's
going to give the bank's immunity from
all kinds of legal liability
well it's precisely because of that deal
that we're not going to have gigantic
class-action lawsuits of defrauded
investors we're going to drag these guys
in the court and prove that they all
committed fraud that they knowingly
disguised the crappiness of these loans
as they were selling them as triple-a
rated securities around the world we're
never gonna get that scene inside a
courtroom we're never gonna see that
evidence dragged out it's been years now
nobody has gone to jail for any of this
stuff and it's it's just not gonna
happen unless unless more pressure is
brought to bear from you know these
people downtown we're just never gonna
see that scene except you know in in no
Me's book and it's a it's a great place
to come you know face to face with what
the evidence would be if we were
actually able to see it and so I think
it's an invaluable opportunity for all
of us and and then I was a really cool
thing and I think everybody should read
it
let me ask you both the questions let's
say after freud novels have become about
psychology so i want to ask you guys
about the psychology of wall street
because when you go to occupy wall
street a lot of people are frustrated
and pissed off at what has went down in
you know the last seven to eight years
so the question is tell us know me about
the villain in your character in Matt
Taibbi someone has said in order to work
at the highest levels of Wall Street you
have to be a sociopath
I mean that's a direct quote what is
your understanding of people's motives
and people's psychology over the last
five years and what's gone on so in the
novelistic sense and in the real-life
sense because there has to be a clear
separation of how you act and who you
think you are at those top levels and
not because they're CEOs not because
you're running the morgan bank but
because of everything that made you able
to take that position and and I I
continue we could talk I continue to
think about this just in a more
psychological emotional sense you know
er you associate path first and that's
how you get to that position like is it
a latent quality it is it and and when
you get there it's sort of it's sort of
flushes out or you know when you get the
power is that sort of like you know
water on a plant and it I don't know or
is it something that that you know it's
it's a lain human thing or inhuman thing
but one of the things that struck me in
looking at the history of the Morgan
Bank in Jack Morgan who's CEO JP
Morgan's son is that when he was
actually called to trial in 1933 and
this is for real in in Washington at the
Pecora Commission
it looked into all of what Wall Street
had done up until the 29 crash he was
like really steely and really common and
the way the media portrayed it at the
time you know he's he's he's so cool and
he's so calm and he said that and you
know there was a little circus a mini
girl or something that stepped on and on
his lap and and he was so nice to her
and and in the way like after all of
what happened there was turning around
of the media almost embracing the same
people they're also running headlines
about sensationally the court trials so
it was it was just always this weird
sort of dichotomy of you know they're up
there and and and so forth and what I
did in the novel and I don't want to
give away the scene because it's it's
not things happen there are twists and
stuff but but but the the Jack Morgan
character really is based on Jack Morgan
the Morgan bank really is is is Morgan
back and there's a lot of elements I
think of crime and forget calling it
securities or forget labeling it as
anything complicated lying about
something for profit you know that that
is very simple to achieve you know it's
it's as simple as a signature on a
document it's as simple as two separate
documents that save different things you
know it doesn't have to be a complicated
CDO credit link derivative times a
million like it doesn't need to be that
the the mechanism for pulling one over
on anyone who buys this stuff requires
that same sense of separatism from the
people that are buying it and to me
that's a sociopathic quality now now in
here and again not giving away the plot
but there are other elements that that
flesh out the sociopathic quality of the
villain which you can read but but I
think that the elements of one kind of
crime versus another kind of crime are
pretty much the same yeah I totally
agree me first I think the the one of
the first ways you have to answer that
question is is to identify what what
happened like what's a typical crime
that went on during this period this
this recent period is take a
you know a banker is gonna sell you know
250 million dollars of mortgage-backed
securities to let's say the state
pension fund of Minnesota so let's all
be clear about what this is some guy who
knows he's selling to a gigantic load of
extremely risky subprime mortgages that
are likely to blow up he's selling a
whole bunch of crap to a state punch
pension fund so that's the the
retirement savings of working class
people janitors teachers policemen
firemen this guy is gonna spill from old
lady's and old old people that's think
that's what he's doing when he's when
he's selling this big block of
mortgage-backed securities to his state
pension fund or to CalPERS or at
whatever and in order to do that I mean
you're gonna make an enormous amount of
money and you're never gonna see those
people and all you got to do is sign a
few documents and hit a few strokes in
Europe on your computer and you're
emotionally I think right I mean these
guys are completely dissociated from
from the results of their activities and
I think a lot of them they came to
genuinely believe in the righteousness
of what they were doing they they
believe that somehow this was you know
the survival of the fittest that somehow
all this this trading this capital a
capitalist activity was weeding out the
weak and and it was going to create
liquidity and somehow it helped the
economy in the end but the reality is
what they were doing is just stealing
from old people and and and and the weak
and there's no way to do that and let
unless you completely cut off your
conscience and morality I mean I think
it gets back to that in the famous
experiment where people are told to turn
the dial if and they're gonna hear the
screams in the other room and and they
they with the results show is that
people tend to do that as long as an
authority figure tells them that it's
okay and I think that's what went on in
this in this community there was a
mantra that kind of existed generally
that this stuff was all right right and
and it's a right right it was your job
right right you had to write so we'd
love to hear from you guys so we're
gonna circulate a mic and if you could
just ask a concise question and please
speak into the mic
because you're being recorded thank you
hi well this is a really awesome honor
and so thank you for doing this
my question is speaking about training
for which you get into these jobs what
part of the problem is you know rooted
in the fact that academic economics is
sort of has this inherent problem in
which professors or people write papers
but they don't have to disclose who
funded the papers so they could write
like documents about oh you know
currency exchanging is so much you know
this great invention but it they don't
have to actually disclose it Forex the
you know currency trader is the one that
sponsored the paper and how if that's
the case do we like turn that back how
can we force academia to like disclose
information if they're getting funded by
certain financial institutions when they
write papers I think your question is
part of part of the bigger issue of the
transparency notion of what happens on
on Wall Street and whether it's the
papers that did people write about it or
the articles or whatever and what
actually goes on and there's there is
still a lot of sort of cloak-and-dagger
as to what goes on actually everyday and
a lot of the documentation that does
comes out is very difficult to sort of
process and doesn't necessarily have all
the information that you need and
therefore you know if you're in academia
and you decide oh my bigger problem
actually with academia or some certain
academic papers is that those people
don't necessarily live through the
things they're talking about you know so
they'll be talking about currency swaps
or credit derivatives and they've never
structured one you know I don't believe
you know you've mentioned I don't
believe anyone in Washington knows what
a swap is and you don't have to in
day-to-day life and that that's part of
what you know Lila discovers in the book
you don't need to know a lot but but if
you're making decisions and you're
enabling conditions that allow whatever
it is you don't understand to devastate
the economy then it's your
responsibility to get out a spreadsheet
and just like
look at some numbers and and or find a
person or do anything that gives you
some understanding and at least have a
basis for what you're what you're
deciding upon which does not exist in
any of the people I've spoken with in
Washington yeah and just quickly the
only thing I that add to that is that
it's not just that the university level
I think there's been a lot written and
then was in an inside job about how the
banks are sponsoring academics and
they're behind a lot of those research
papers but there's a tremendous movement
afoot for all the banks are getting
heavily involved in sponsoring secondary
education even elementary school
education if you go into the communities
all across the country there are a lot
of these deals where a bank will come to
a strug community that's struggling
financially and they'll say here here's
five million dollars for your school
system but in return we want you to
dissolve your teachers union or you know
we want this or that and they're it's
kind of like the IMF World Bank
structural adjustment method where we
give you a whole bunch of money in
return we want your ideological
cooperation on this X Y & Z right
exactly and and they're they're very
very keen on doing that it and I think
it shows how how far-reaching their
vision is about society they don't have
any immediate benefit to doing that and
they're spending a lot of money on it
and that tells you that they're that
they have a very very broad vision for
how they want to impact the world and
keep the information out oh hi you two
are heroes so thank you very much and
this is sort of to both of you do you
think we can stop them at the New
Hampshire primary before they turn this
country into okona Mad Max a nightmare
world you know one of the things that
occupy wall street is really bringing
out is that there aren't any obvious
electoral solutions to a lot of this I
mean I think we kind of we've kind of
gone the route of trying to fix this at
the at the ballot box because you know
the Democratic Party the Republican
Party there if you look historically the
Democrats actually have
probably dirtier hands in terms of
deregulating this mess then the
Republicans do and if you look at what
happened in dodd-frank the negotiations
last year that was a fiasco as well you
know there are a lot of well-meaning
people in Washington you know there were
33 votes to to start breaking up the
banks and the brown Kaufman bill
amendment but you know that's it's not
quite enough you know I I don't I don't
think there's any I mean do you think
there's there's a solution out there no
presidential level
well the presidential level definitely
in the fact that you know President
Obama has Tim Geithner as a Treasury
secretary right right there is a it's a
rubber stamp to the idea of subsidizing
bailing out whatever term you use for
the way Wall Street acts and the way
Wall Street will continue to act it's
it's a big rubber stamp status quo let's
let's not touch anything because entire
sector is not about to turn around say
oops I made a mistake I shouldn't have
really backed a Bank of America just
because they bought all the slick crap
from countrywide and Merrill Lynch which
by the way I said they could do you know
in between my roles the New York Fed and
Ben Bernanke at the role of the Fed head
they're not going to turn around and
ever admit a mistake which which bio is
part of the whole sociopathic mess there
there's there's there's the culpability
at the most powerful level you know will
you keep say banks big you keep them
structurally as they are you you agree
to large mergers that shouldn't ever
happen because they are very unstable
for the rest of the economy those people
have no incentive interest ability to
consider anything they've done a mistake
I mean look what happened right there
you know you had this mess that was
because of concentration of capital and
what was their statement they
concentrated it more they took the
residue from all these banks and they
Jan them together and made them working
more dangerous and today actually
they're there they're real mer stamping
that you know Bank of America like my
favorite negative Bank is today I change
but is taking a lot of the stuff that
was toxic from Merrill Lynch which was
something they purchased in the wake of
the financial crisis component of 2008
and they're basically putting it on
their deposit side so because banks are
not just big but complex they can be
like you know all this stuff
here that we don't understand it's gonna
lose money we're just gonna mix it up
with deposits and that way you really
have to back us in case all of that
fails in case you didn't do that enough
the first time like we're doing it today
like today this this you know the Fed is
approving this so it's not only that
we've learned nothing we continue we're
going backwards right now I think right
and then both parties have an equal an
annuities quick comment when people with
the protests are accused of being
conspiracy theorists I wish the screen
read this is what they mean thanks yeah
I actually that asked it's about stuff
that that you know financial services
companies are doing now like there seems
to be all this volatility in the market
like there's this weird thing that
Goldman tried to do with Facebook there
seems to be some kind of tech bubble
emerging and and it there are appear to
be investment banks shorting entire
countries in in Europe if I'm unless I
misunderstand that it's very disturbing
to me that you would bet on the
destruction of Italy that's that's I
wouldn't want to win that bet but I
don't know if you have any views about
that I mean that stuff is so is such a
classic example of what modern Wall
Street is all about it's it's like take
the example of Greece right like you
know Goldman goes into Greece and they
and they sell this country a gigantic
raft of interest rate swaps to basically
what a what our interest rate swaps do
you have a country that has a whole
bunch of debt they can't afford to pay
it right now and it's just really just a
mechanism to push the debt into the
future so that they the the current
spate of politicians doesn't have to
deal with it and the future generation
of politicians has a big bomb that's
going to go off in their face so it's
it's basically this symbiotic deal
between Wall Street and the sitting
politicians it's like will will lend you
a bunch of money now as so that future
politicians can give us a big bribe
later
well of course Goldman does this deal
right which is going to enormous lead it
stabilizes Greece it makes their
long-term outlook extremely negative and
what do they do right away they set up a
mechanism to short Greece because they
themselves
sold them this stuff that is going to
blow up and that's an exact repeat of
what happened in the mortgage industry
where they were selling this stuff and
they turn right around in bed against it
and then when they broke their bookies
doing that and couldn't get their bets
paid up they made us pay it off through
through the bailouts and that's that's
exactly what's going on with this euro
bailout right now they're gonna get
somebody else to pay off those bets and
actually again in terms of history
repeating itself that day I was telling
you about Black Thursday six big bankers
got into a room and they decided to pool
up the market they put in their own
money it wasn't a federal money but but
still put it one of those was the head
of what was chased at the time now it's
JP Morgan Chase was a Morgan bank there
was chase Lee they've gone together and
he was in this room and he's like I'll
pledge this it's you know our stock is
gonna be worth it we're gonna put in the
market all these you know little people
are gonna buy stuff everything is going
to be great and meanwhile he's set up
like five companies and like haneda run
by you know the names of his relatives
and he's shorting the stock right this
guy's name's al Wiggins he's shorting
the stock he's in the room they call the
New York Times right after that Wall
Street you know bankers save the day
blah blah blah the real headlines all
over the place and uh and he's off
shorting the stock and a year later when
the Depression starts to really take
hold he's in Europe trying to figure out
how to basically get money out of the
European side of the crash right so it's
exactly the same is it make money where
you can when it falls apart like move on
I mean not that that's kind of the modus
and again it's not complicated and I
think the one thing is one of the good
things that's coming down the Occupy
Wall Street movement is that it's
showing you you don't have to know every
single mechanic of every single detail
how this happens you just have to know
that the impact that the the ultimately
result is is bad and that there is a
connection and I think that that you
know I I show it in here through Lila
just understanding that it at a base
level like what happens if one person
makes one bad decision on one bad deal
and like how that not just escalates in
financial world and in economy but how
that escalates in in people's real lives
everyday at home and
family in in terms of mortality and so
there there's so many connections
No
Thank You Man for letting everybody know
about how Goldman propped up a grease
than only to short it really accurate
portrayal you know Milton Friedman said
that the Federal Reserve caused a Great
Depression
and I would if you go along with that
line of reasoning that the Federal
Reserve constricted the or didn't allow
for the monetary supplies to increase if
you look at this current crisis would
you say that the Federal Reserve bears
responsibility as well because of how
they enable the banks to go ahead and
have such an easy supply of money to
lend out that would allow for the
mortgage industry government bears its
responsibility for creating the
regulations but what burden would you
put on the Federal Reserve for that and
would you propose the abolishing of the
Federal Reserve and if you would what
would you put in its place okay this
could be a topic for this is a it's an
excellent question so I'm just going to
give a very short answer that we could
honestly talk about this a lot and it's
a really good question the the Federal
Reserve and and Wall Street are are
symbiotic right there there is printing
money making making the currency cheap
giving out cheap loans is what has
pumped a lot of the the toxic asset
market it's what's what's pumped a lot
of speculation it's what's allowed banks
to survive when they shouldn't be
solvent on the other hand its banks that
are using that money to speculate and
leverage and do all these other things
so it's almost like the nature in which
the Fed has enabled Wall Street to do
what Wall Street does in its current
form is the danger so it is totally a
symbiotic danger back in the Great
Depression and I take issue with Ben
Bernanke's whole I'm a Great Depression
scholar thing I mean I no no I mean I
know he's written a lot of papers and he
spent a lot of time and that's fine
but but again to go back to a banker's a
personal situation one of the bankers
sitting in that room not the guy who's
shorting a stock another one was also
also had a first-class
a seat at the New York Fed at the time
so the head of what was then Citigroup
city national Charles Mitchell was also
sitting at the New York Fed he actually
and this doesn't come up in Ben
Bernanke's papers he was actually trying
to get the Fed to keep rates low into
the crash of 1929 to keep money cheap
and keep the speculation going because
his bank was going to be screwed if
rates went up when he couldn't handle
that and he had a lot of stock in his
bank and didn't want that to happen so
he basically increased the bubble that
became the crash personally I mean other
people but you know he had it he had a
personal impact and right now we have
Jamie Dimon who's the head of JPMorgan
Chase is sitting at the same seat the
same spot at the New York Fed able to
have the conversations you know with Tim
Geithner officer you know to talk about
we need rates low now we need cheap
loans now you know if we don't the
economy is going to get worse or
whatever conversations I need 30 billion
in guarantees the barber and and and and
and I'll just keep that forever by the
way let's never talk about the fact that
I only own Bear Stearns because the Fed
IES are you know financing it and the
Treasury Department's all okay with that
so it's not the fact that the Fed can
both regulate banks is allowed to tell
them how to behave or not behave to
emerge or not to emerge which they never
say not they always say to and print
money when they screw up is a completely
yeah bad economic policy it's it's
morally hazardous and in all of those
things so having the Fed being control
of regulating the banking system when it
also is allowed to save it when it
screws up is is just not good for the
rest of the economy it just had one
really quick thing about to that I mean
one of the criticisms that people like
no no me night me got when we talked
about all this stuff as well you know
you shouldn't criticize people at
Goldman and JP Morgan because these guys
are these guys are really smart they
earn their money because they're the
smartest guys in the world and and they
they deserve to get all that money that
they earned because they're just so
smart if you're if you're borrowing
money billions of dollars from the Fed
zero percent and then you're going out
lending it at five percent to the rest
of us or 25 percent in a credit card
twenty ninth or twenty nine percent and
that's how you're making your money what
kind of does it take a genius to do that
I mean god I mean a three-year-old could
make a billion dollars if you have that
kind of setup it's it's criminal what
these guys that the Fed it's basically a
gigantic ATM machine that all these
banks get to use they get free money and
then they lend it all out to us at
market rates and that's their business
that's how they own that the the
Washington called this recapitalizing
the bank's after the crash and that's
all it is this free money go get
yourselves well and then charge us the
market rate and there's a reason why
there's not a lot of money that comes
back out there's a reason why it's hard
to negotiate a mortgage or renegotiate
and to renegotiate a student loan or to
get a small business loan because they
wouldn't want to do that if they can
basically be getting money for free and
and using it in any capacity there's no
is there's no attachment there's no
there's no obligation there's no
economic obligation to actually spread
it around and there wasn't back then
except then the the issue was there were
more farmers and other kinds of
businessmen and there was a lot of
conversation which doesn't happen in Ben
Bernanke's papers about how they were
trying to suppress loans to the farmers
which ultimately also helped create the
Great Depression and and now it's you
know it's not farmers it's kind of
everybody and farmers also but but but
it's the same mechanism it's it's the we
keep it low we restrain when we have
problems we get bailed out when we have
problems and whatever happens on the
outside it's an accident of nature it's
the economy it's the cycle it's it's the
way things are yeah I I have a question
um I know what it's like for a typical
day in a bookstore what's it like to
work for demos for a think-tank what's
it to what how is it structured okay no
me ways for demos to she's a senior
fellow my typical day is I have a series
of long-term projects I'm working that
are related on culture and politics and
I work on those but I also follow what's
going on on a daily
whether it be Occupy Wall Street whether
it be election issues and I'll write and
comment and research on those so there's
no typical day per se but that's what I
typically do it's also very much me what
you do is it's also very much about
what's happening right now and how these
policies whether they're on democracy
where that economic policies are
impacting people right now and rather
than just saying they are actually
coming up with you know good solid
information that people can use when
they talk about the issue is that very
very much my question gets back to it
something that said that we'd never see
these individuals prosecuted and I hear
that but Eric Schneiderman and Beau
Biden and there is a group of people who
are trying to defend the bondholders and
to make sure that doesn't happen given
everything that's going on with Occupy
Wall Street where Americans are becoming
interested in informed thanks to you and
I hope we see an awful lot more of you
all on TV and everywhere what can we be
doing and how can we Institute some sort
of change to see these people prosecuted
and also to have a better future all the
way around that's that's a good question
I mean they are the obvious answer is
write letters protests to all of these
things I you know I think politicians
are rapidly becoming aware that that if
they sweep this whole foreclosure thing
under the rug that they're playing with
fire I mean there's four million people
already out in the streets because they
lost their homes and that that's just
lighting a fuse if if they if they
decide not to take anybody to jail for
all that stuff and and and and also give
them immunity from civil liability I
think they're making a huge mistake in
politicians you know we saw the Attorney
General in California has already
doubled back I think they're very very
sensitive to public pressure right now
obviously we have a good one here in New
York who's already not going to jump on
board with that but if you're from
another state I think they're listening
so you know
letters put show public support I think
all that stuff is
I mean even though they're not at that
level the Senate or the you know in
Washington per se I think the collective
pressure that they can exude if they
hear what's going on and they're doing
their jobs
you know prosecuting at the foreclosure
fraud level and also taking that all the
way up to the CEO level because that
fraud is something that that remains in
every single asset that is created all
the way up the line from the one home
and the one mortgage that might have
been fraudulently created to you know
the mega CDO wrapped synthetic you know
whatever thing that's on the other side
of that that the fraud continues it
doesn't stop because it's passed to the
next level but I think I think that a I
still say the same you write your
Congressman recomment and there is
something to be said for that I think
the Occupy Wall Street movement so it so
helped to that actually as a
representative movement of everybody is
is useful and also the the Attorney
General route I've been finding more and
more is a good accessible route as well
one of the narratives that that is there
people are trying to the banks are
trying to push about the foreclosure
thing is that this is all about
paperwork this is you know we maybe we
we didn't transfer the deeds properly
that's all this thing is about if that's
not what it's all about this isn't a
massive systemic cover-up where they
were the what they were talking about is
a gigantic industry wide effort at
selling crap as she know number five to
investors all around and and if I think
a couple of AG's like Schneiderman are
that they're on the scent they recognize
that there is a lot of political hay to
be made they mean if you go down that
route with investigating securitization
that whole aspect of all this they could
be making cases to the next century
basically and I think a lot of smart
attorneys general or real are realizing
that that that's where the that's where
the money isn't that and a little push
and they'll go there you know a there
have been some prosecutions but they're
odd though if the a CEO or a member of a
board of directors has a fiduciary
responsibility to his shareholders he'll
always tell you that so if I were a
shareholder and my CEO when he was about
to sell these this junk said oh but
it'll hurt that little old lady in the
pension fund in Minneapolis I could sue
him I could sue him he has to put my
fiduciary responsibilities first and if
the guy is decent as I talked to the
kind of people who are decent what
they'll say is make it against the law
then I won't have to do it in other
words says stop me before I kill again
so there have been some suits but you
know take think back to Enron the suits
were not Enron for raising the price of
electricity in California to the point
that it broke the state and ruined the
educational system but only when you
kept secrets from other shareholders
when you try to pass it off on the
shareholders so it was only on behalf of
shareholders that suits have been
brought I mean that's really a shameful
system these guys will tell you I'm not
even allowed to think about the common
good I would quit we just have to
control I would quibble with that only
in the sense that what these guys were
doing was was criminal it was it was
fraud it was against the law and by and
by doing it was against the law I mean I
hear if you're taking if you're taking a
gigantic batch of subprime mortgages
from country right which you know is a
criminal organization that is that is
giving out fraudulent loans you have
information that you are not moving
along so you also know that right so you
know that and then you're knowingly
unloading them on people and not
disclosing those facts you're committing
a crime and that's incurring a much
bigger liability than potential
liability than missing out in the
profits by not selling that that thing
so I would argue that they they created
a much bigger problem for their
shareholders by doing this than they
than they would have by not doing it
securities fraud laws a lot of this
stuff could be prosecuted the whole
reason the SEC was created was to
investigate a lot well was to basically
keep the kinds of trusts and the kinds
of
things where we were selling Chanel and
calling it Chanel and selling whatever
else was inside it that was basically
the SCC's job was to protect the public
from public fraud from the securities
that were created by these institutions
that impact the public being fraudulent
you know so it's it's it's a really yeah
I don't get to prosecute this stuff but
I mean it's it's it's very it's much
less complicated than they make it out
to be
yes well someone kind of asked a related
question about solutions and your answer
kind of scares me a little bit because a
lot of what your books are about is how
these solutions aren't working right so
these solutions right like presidential
we think they could yeah I think there
are basic solutions the question do you
protect the economy the general
population do you protect the banking
institutions
more's though doesn't there need to be a
shift in the way we view these things
though because I think a lot of problem
is like Matt mentions in his book that
there isn't this isn't seen as
criminality by everybody and so what can
we do to kind of change the mind state
of our country where we actually see
this is outright criminality because I
feel like I just personally I feel like
that's a lot of the problem that's
probably on the media more than anything
right I mean I think security yeah
they've committed securities fraud
securities fraud is illegal they've
committed illegal acts they should be
prosecuted and penalized you know we
don't we don't see a lot of that but you
know as regards solutions I think like
there's there's are going to be a huge
debate down the road about things that
need to be done and and you know the
right is going to have its traditional
solution of deregulation and and the
other the other side is going to say
let's have more regulation but I think
even before we get there there's a lot
of really obvious steps when we have to
end this sort of unhealthy plutocrat
you know symbiotic relationship between
government and Wall Street that but
neither side agrees on I think I'm gonna
make anybody on the right or the left
agrees that our tax dollars should be
going to pay Lloyd Blankfein's bonus
right I mean that I don't think nobody
agrees to that nobody nobody believes
that you know Stevie : or George Soros
or John Paulson should be paying half
the tax rate of a fireman or a teacher I
think that's something that everybody
can agree upon so there are a lot of
things break up the banks a lot of
things that are obvious solutions and
then there's you know the more
complicated policy discussion down the
road one of the reasons I wrote a novel
instead of a nonfiction this time around
was because there's that you sometimes
have to take a break from like yelling
about the solutions for like almost I
don't ever many years I've been doing
this it was sort of like let me let me
go into at least another time another
period look at this a different way you
know touch it are you inside of it
because the solutions aren't that
difficult either it's it's it's the will
to get there that's the will problem my
name is George I be down to Occupy Wall
Street a number of times and my
contribution is in a pictorial I'd like
to hand it to you
it made meet the press in in their first
15 seconds of last two Sundays ago I
hung that that's a skeleton holding a
placard saying throw me some crumbs and
I think it's how the 99% certainly feel
it's been very well photographed my
question though I'm trying to get the
group down there to focus on what I
think of the two most important
overarching initiatives which Dylan
Ratigan seems to have one covered and
that's a campaign finance reform but I
think that's gonna be a really I think
that's going to be a really difficult
thing to do a constitutional amendment
it's got to be carefully written with
you know tricky parameters and the worst
part is that we need both of our
illustrious politicians to vote on it
and now since the debt ceiling crisis
when they played political chicken with
each other we don't seem to have any
confidence in either one of them so my
question to you is question sort of is
do you think
campaign finance reform is one of the
best ways to go about fixing what's
wrong with our government or do we also
need to actually change our voting
system from single vote into something
like score voting to level the playing
field so that third and fourth party
candidates will have an equal chance to
win this and will be able to actually
vote instead of haven't been forced to
feel that we have to vote for the
Democrat or the Republican will be able
to actually vote for anybody that we
want to and everybody that we want to
and pick the guys who are the more
generally preferred moderate centrists
when they'll they're not even on the
ballot now so that's sort of a question
real simple answer that yeah if we get
money out of politics that leaves real
issues and real solutions and real
activities in politics and and so you
know the campaign finance reform the
fact that we went in the again this is
another thing the last few years we go
in the opposite direction of what makes
sense to be more palatable for the
general population and and the Supreme
Court decision regarding campaign
finance reform is just another example
of a recent happening of that so if the
people that run are you know require the
money that comes in from whether it's
corporate sponsorship or Wall Street and
you know President Obama this year is
second largest group contributor is the
financial industry so you know if
they're keeping your you or your job
you're gonna sort of do what you need to
do to stay in power and so that
definitely should be disconnected just
just really quickly on that you know my
own personal experience from covering
the dodd-frank bill and when I was down
in the Senate at that time really
interesting statistic the financial
services industry had 2,000 lobbyists in
the halls of Congress during that bill
the other side which was like Americans
for financial reform had 60 volunteer
lobbyists and I was I remember very
distinctly being in one senator's office
actually with one of our senators and
not having room to stand in the in the
waiting room because there were so many
industry lobbyists and the in the
waiting
so the problem of money in this look
there was a lot of reforms that got
passed in the dodd-frank bill despite
this avalanche of money that got thrown
at all of these these members of
Congress which just shows you how you
know it was what they were asking for
was so wrong and and the other side was
so it was so appealing to the to what
whatever was left of the conscience of
these congressional members that they
actually did do a few things despite the
fact that all the money was on one side
and none of it was on the other side so
I think if you can get some at least
even half the money out you let you'll
start to see a lot of movement I think
you know that's question here okay just
by the way Matt to your point about the
Greek swap deal the goldman partner
range that is now the head of the public
debt management agency for greece
socialists by the way know me do you
really think the dodd-frank d--
concentrates financial power or doesn't
it recon --scent rate it by making it a
further concentrated by raising the
transaction costs to a point where and
complexity to a point where only the
largest institutions can navigate
through it even more than that the
dodd-frank bill does does nothing to
change the current complexity or size
and it does not split up banks it does
not reduce their ability to create
complex assets and call them gold when
they are not it does it I don't find the
dodd-frank bill does very much of
anything
that will be meaningful at all so you
know one one member of Congress that I
talked to had a great way of describing
what happened with dodd-frank does
anyone here read old man in the sea you
know so the guy from Sherman goes like
it catches this huge fish and he's all
stoked about it and then he starts going
back to shore and by the time he gets
back to she was like a skeleton left
behind the boat that's exactly what
happened at dodd-frank there are all
these great ideas that came out in the
beginning and by the
all the lobbyists got done with that
bill there was literally nothing left it
all got eaten away in those last minute
discussions behind the scenes and it was
that was a sort of a classic example of
how the public doesn't really see how
the real work gets done all those public
things we saw on c-span and the
arguments on the floor of the house that
really it just disappeared in the middle
of the night and those committee
discussions which is really really sad
though we did have a point in time where
they they did pass so I mean it didn't
now which is again very sad for now but
when they did pass in 1933 they did
create a somewhat more stable banking
system slash economic environment and so
again those solutions exist the the
problem is getting them to happen before
that we have one really another thing to
talk about the thank you to the tenant
museum were kind of strand bookstores
kind of going Oprah Winfrey but one
person under their seat has a two-person
ship for the tenement Museum for for
Pierre and let me step research for the
tap
they get the win so thank you so much
rich know me and Matt for such a
spirited and you guys for great
questions spirited discussion you're
watching book TV on c-span too